[Music]
foreign
has died after being shot by armed
police in South London Chris cover
when he was shot dead in streatham Hill
the family of a man shot dead by police
since South London have said he was due
to become a father
on the 5th of September 2022 the
metropolitan police shot and killed 24
year old Chris Cabell
the vehicle he was driving was linked to
previous Firearms incident but he was
unidentified and unarmed
I need him to tell me the truth I'm
waiting for them I need an answer
his killing spots Nationwide protest
but in a week where the UK gained a new
prime minister and lost their
longest-serving Monarch his story was
somewhat overshadowed it's a national
importance and I think the
underestimating
how upset how outraged the community are
the metropolitan police officer has now
been suspended from his post
the officers don't want to discharge a
farm it's an absolute Last Resort
I want to try and make sense of what
happened that night and understand what
comes next in this ongoing investigation
into his death
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
's family finally got the chance to
mourn
[Music]
hundreds of his friends and loved ones
came together at this church in Croydon
foreign
despite their grief his parents allowed
us to capture this day on camera
the 24 year old rapper and aspiring
architect was about to become a father
his baby girl was born just days before
his funeral
his fiancee karima's family were there
to pay tribute
because I miss you so much
there was pain
prayers and this clear message from his
cousin
Chris here
his body is a representation
of what we go through as a community
he didn't deserve this
there's no way he deserves this
and I'll try to justify it
but what happened was wrong
what happened what was wrong and I'm
praying that we get Justice
because Chris isn't here but we're still
here we can keep fighting for him
I mean it's not just for Chris
it's for all the other brothers and
cousins
you know uncles
[Music]
they've waited weeks to say goodbye but
until what could be a series of lengthy
legal processes are over real closure
won't be possible
and that's where this case gets
complicated
foreign
to me but it's also quite difficult to
cover
that's because the iopc the independent
office for police conduct are
investigating the case so that means
there are so many legal limits as to
what we can say
but what we do have from them is a
statement and we're going to use that
statement that outline of events to
visualize what happened that night
[Music]
on the evening of Monday the 5th of
September 2022 Chris Cabell is driving
an Audi through South London
the car was believed to be linked to
Firearms incident the day before with an
automatic number plate recognition
marker placed on it
there are over 2 000 ampr cameras in
London recording every single car that
passes
and when Chris kappa's registration
plate was captured the police were
alerted immediately
before they started their shift that day
the Met police officers had been given a
briefing the car was brought to their
attention but Chris caber's name was not
mentioned
the Audi was recognized by officers
parked here at the side of the a202 in
camberwell green they were in an
unmarked armed response car
the officers then started to follow
Chris Kaba at around 9 52 pm
they continue to follow him through
these streets with no lights or sirens
for around 15 minutes
he was driving towards streatham Hill
but what's not clear from the iopc
statement is which way he went there are
multiple routes he could have taken
what we do know is that around 1007 PM
Chris Kappa made this left turn from New
Park Road onto kirkstall Gardens
a mocked police response vehicle was
already waiting for him there
it was meant to join the other police
vehicles following the Audi once it
passed the junction
one of the officers inside the marked
arv was nx121
nx121 is the code name being given to
the officer involved in the incident to
protect their identity that's the
officer who's been suspended the officer
who discharged their firearm that night
once Chris Cava made the left turn armed
officers left their cars and approached
the car he was in the iopc says contact
was made between the car he was driving
and the police vehicles
this word contact is really vague but we
know it's a key moment in what happened
after this that series of events that
led up to him losing his life
this is where it happened
this is where officer nx121 got out of
their car then stood in front of the
vehicle Chris Cabell was driving and
fired a single shot that shot pierced
the front windscreen of his car hitting
him in the head
officers at the scene then gave Chris
Kaba first aid before he was taken to
King's College Hospital where he was
pronounced dead at 12 16 am on Tuesday
the 6th of September
his family say they were told 11 hours
later
[Music]
the iopc statement is the only public
information available about what
happened that night
investigators who took over the scene
the very next morning are piecing
together witness statements forensic and
Ballistic evidence
and they've got body cam footage worn by
the officers involved
[Music]
we know the Firearms officer was
suspended from Duty a week after firing
that fatal shot
but because of this ongoing homicide
investigation it's not possible to talk
to the police or to anyone who might
have witnessed what happened on the
night
but I wanted to try and understand how
Firearms operations should play out and
under what kind of circumstances a
weapon might be discharged
so I've got in touch with Dal Babu a
former commander in the Mets Elite
Firearms unit
through the process of firearms
operation from picking up someone who
you may follow or pursue right through
to how how it looks and what you need to
do the way it would start is that you
would have you'd assess the intelligence
because you'd be signing off this
operation is a pre-planned operation
and you'd be signing that off so you
would be gripping the rail at the old
bayley if things had gone horribly wrong
so you know I'd be meticulous in the
planet I'd want to know what the
intelligence was how good that
intelligence was how accurate it was
then identify the individuals that we
were trying to to stop
uh and detain though officers don't want
to discharge a farm you know it's an
absolute Last Resort the Met does about
4 000 operations a year uh about a
thousand are pre-planned and three
thousand are spontaneous and so and out
of that every on average of the last 10
years the the Met will discharge uh
firearm that results in an injury or a
death to a person twice a year on
average so you imagine you know how many
operations there are and it's to
discharge a weapon is very very rare
very extremely rare
growing up in South London Chris Cabell
was part of a well-known mobo nominated
rap Collective his death sent shockwaves
across his music fraternity and his
local community then it went further
a campaign for justice began immediately
after his death at the Forefront his
cousin Jefferson
become about spring it's someone that
you all know
Jefferson let's give him some love now
[Music]
before this he was a teacher he quit the
job he loved to become the family
spokesperson
it's hard like having it
I've lost my appetite like I haven't
really been eaten like as much I've been
sleeping like super late
and sometimes like when I do go to bed
and I close my eyes like
I literally can't sleep you know I'm
just thinking about him thinking about
how he felt you know those last moments
sometimes I literally feel like he's in
the room with me and this is love and
hopefully the baby eats her life
although this is unbelievable tragic
situation not just for the family but
for the community for
for anyone realistically it's a tragic
situation
but once again hopefully there's change
that's going to come from this Chris
please come back the Kaaba family want
answers now and crucially they want to
know if a race could have been a factor
in the fatal shooting
[Applause]
it's hard it's hard because we feel like
there's no sense of urgency from the
aisle PC you know there's no sense of
urgency Chris was killed him or you know
he was shot dead on on Monday night
um and it was on Friday that they opened
the investigation you know so it's it's
hard because as much as we want a
foreign investigation and we want them
to do things properly we also need that
sense of urgency and we need them to you
know understand that the family and the
public and what you know the wider
Community
um are taking this very serious
black lives matter
black lives matter
black lives matter
lies matter
in the weeks and months since his death
Chris caba's family have organized
joined and inspired events across the
country
within days thousands took to the
streets but because of the Queen's death
and the attention it received Across the
Nation many feel it's a movement that
went largely unnoticed
[Applause]
you have people mourning in a
celebratory way for the queen
celebrating a long life a long time on
the throne and a life well lived whereas
these people are mourning and they are
angry I think the people down there were
fueled by the fact that the world wasn't
watching their plight and something that
they thought would keep on happening and
has been happening if anything that
anger about the fact that there weren't
as many eyeballs as there should have
been in in their opinion was a big part
of the protest the main part is
obviously the fact that 24 hour men have
been killed by the police but the second
part was we feel like you should be
watching this you should be watching us
someone's been killed someone who should
have lived a long life too is no longer
here that was a massive part of all of
this
the restrained moyad
by his legs
every year a demonstrations held in
Trafalgar Square for the families who
have lost loved ones at the hands of the
police
this year Chris caba's name was added to
the list they're calling it a
remembrance procession in which they
commemorate the lives of people who have
lost their lives in police custody
people have died at the hands of the
police in incidents like the killing of
Chris Kappa for other ones as well
involving people who are having mental
health crises as well as having some
kind of contact with the police they're
going to start here Trafalgar Square and
then make their way down to Downing
Street and they'll be delivering a
letter to the Prime Minister the new
prime minister Rishi sunak in which
they're asking for their demands to be
met and for authorities not just the
Prime Minister Home Secretary as well
and the mayor of London to look at the
instances and these examples of deaths
in custody and to try and get Justice
for their families
it was pulled out of that car with a
bullet in his head
he deserves that
we've won every single police officer to
know that they are not exempt from the
law
the family will fight to ensure that
Chris's name will be a name that is
associated with family
Chris's name will be a name that is
associated with perseverance
Chris's name will be a name that is
associated with love
and Chris's name will be a name that is
associated with Justice
Chris rest in peace little bubble we
miss you we love you and we will fight
for you justice for Chris cover
okay
their brains their hearts
[Music]
once the families reached Downing Street
they hand delivered a letter to number
10 demanding action wanting a response
from the people in power
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
understandably the Kaaba family want to
see something done and soon the iopcs
say their independent homicide
investigation could take six to nine
months to conclude
but the lawyer representing the family
is
he says cases like this one take far too
long
time scales
are just appalling that timeline that
the iopc gives six to nine months isn't
to investigate the crime necessarily or
the suspected crime is to investigate
everything that may have happened that
may give rise to disciplinary or
criminal proceeding
so inevitably that's six to nine months
then gets prolonged so we have families
waiting years from the beginning of
Investigation to a decision on
um criminal or disciplinary charges and
what told us that take on grieving
families that you're looking at years in
some cases exactly obviously if you're
grieving for someone's loss and you want
there to be Justice the longer that can
be brought about the longer you're
suffering wanting to have answers
wanting TCP be for someone to be held
accountable it takes an enormous toll on
people's lives
another problem according to him is the
way police officers are treated in the
immediate aftermath of incidents like
this
he argues that questioning isn't
rigorous or quick enough
the opposite of what would happen in a
civilian case
to my mind it's just unacceptable that
Within
hours of becoming involved in the case
it's okay for the police officers
involved in a particular incident
however fast-moving however traumatic
for the police officers for them to just
give the most basic accounts
not be questioned allowed to go home and
Weeks Later months later they are first
questioned under caution that's a clear
difference a a a huge difference between
how any other suspect in a criminal case
would be dealt with and that has to be
wrong
so I got in touch with the iopc to try
and understand more about their time
frames and processes
they couldn't talk specifically about
Chris caba's case because the
investigation is still ongoing
but they did email me with some general
information which does shed some light
and wider investigations can be so
lengthy
here it says that they're often
dependent on a number of external expert
reports which can include pathology
toxicology ballistics and use of force
they also say that they sympathize with
bereaved families but it's really
important that their investigations are
robust
I think from reading this message
they're trying to get across that
they're working very hard on improving
their timelines and that investigations
are quicker than their predecessor the
ipcc but they're also acknowledging that
they've got plenty of work to do as well
police shootings are rare but when they
do happen the iopc's investigation is
only the first step in what can often be
very lengthy legal proceedings
I've managed officers who have been
involved in shootings and they have been
under scrutiny and scrutiny is
absolutely right it needs to be done but
they've been under scrutiny for seven
and a half years what happens then they
go into that lengthy process you have
independent scrutiny I think that's a
key thing here it's not down to the
police to oversee that investigation so
it will be the independent office of
police conduct they'll conduct an
investigation it will be the economist
Economist offset they'll be asking the
questions if they'd been a fatality you
would have the crown prosecution service
so you've got three independent bodies
and individuals that there will
scrutinize it so it go it's out of the
hands of the police and that's quite
right you know it shouldn't be in-house
thank you
ladies and gentlemen after weeks of
waiting for his body Chris kappa's
family have laid him to rest
but they won't have closure and until
they have answers
he didn't die in vain
you know like I want
he's deaf
to mean something you know and if his
death could prevent
more deaths
then that would have been something good
that's come from it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]